>> WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE THAT SAID THE
AFGHANISTAN SECURITY FORCES
COULD WITHSTAND THE TALIBAN
OFFENSE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO ADVISE ON
MILITARY POLICIES AND A MARINE
COMMANDER.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED
TO ADVISE.
THOSE PEOPLE DIED IN VAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE SENIOR LEADERS
THAT OWN UP AND SAY WE DID NOT
DO THIS WELL IN THE END.
>> Laura: THAT MAN A LT. COL. IS
SITTING IN THE BRIG AND FACES
A COURT MARTIAL FOR CALLING OUT
THE INEPTITUDE OF THE MILITARY
DECISION MAKING.
WHILE HE IS IN JAIL, THE LEADERS
PEDALLED EXCUSES FOR THEIR
FAILURES IN IT AFGHANISTAN
TODAY.
>> THE WITHDRAWAL OF THOSE
FORCES WOULD LEAD TO THE
COLLAPSE OF THE AFGHAN MILITARY
FORCES.
>> YES, MY ASSESSMENT WAS BACK
IN THE FALL OF 2020 AND REMAINED
CONSISTENT WE SHOULD KEEP
A STATE OF 2500 UP TO 3500.
>> Laura: JOINING MOR THE LT.
COL.'S PARENTS CATHY AND STU.
YOUR REACTION TO YOUR SON'S
IMPRISONMENT WHEN THEY WERE
PLAYING THE BLAME SHIFTING GAME
SAYING WE WOULD HAVE LEFT TROOPS
THERE.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> OUR SON CALLED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING TODAY I
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY ACCEPTED
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I AM EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED.
IT'S NO COINCIDENCE IN MY
OPINION THAT THEY PUT A GAG
ORDER ON HIM AND THEY PUT HIM IN
PRISON THE DAY BEFORE THEY HAD
TO APPEAR IN FRONT OF SENATORS
AND TOMORROW IN FRONT OF
CONGRESSMEN.
I THINK THAT IS FAIRLY AN ACT OF
COWARDICE.
WE ARE PROUD OF OUR SON.
OUR SON IS A HERO.
HE FOUGHT FOR THIS COUNTRY FOR
17 YEARS.
HE'S BEEN ON 5 DEPLOYMENTS AND
TAUGHT COUNTLESS MEN AND WOMEN.
THE MARINES HAVE FAST TRACKED
HIM IN HIS CAREER.
UNTIL 30 DAYS AGO, HE WAS A HERO
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF THE MARINE
CORPS.
ON AUGUST 26th, WHEN 13 OF OUR
SERVICEMEN DIED IN THE KABUL
AIRPORT, SOMETHING INSIDE OF OUR
SON SNAPPED.
HE WAS ANGRY.
HE IN PRINCIPLE -- HE IS A VERY
COURAGEOUS AND PRINCIPLED MAN --
BUT WITH THAT HAPPENED, HE HAD
TO GO AND ASK HIS LEADERS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HE HAD MANY ACTIVE DUTY MARINES
AND VETERANS WERE ASKING IS IT
WORTH IT?
HE CALLED FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WITHIN 12 HOURS THEY REMOVED HIM
FROM HIS POSITION.
IT'S BEEN DOWNHILL FROM THERE.
>> Laura: CATHY, YOUR SON IS IN
MILITARY PRISON TONIGHT.
AS A MOTHER, WHEN YOU WATCH
GENERAL MARK MILLEY ASKED POINT
BLANK IF HE WOULD RESIGN, I WANT
YOUR REACTION AFTER WE PLAY HIS
ANSWER.
>> THERE IS A SENIOR MILITARY
OFFICER, RESIGNING IS A SERIOUS
THING AND A POLITICAL ACT IF I
RESIGN IN PROTEST.
MY DAD DIDN'T GET A CHOICE TO
RESIGN AND THOSE KIDS DON'T GET
A CHOICE TO RESIGN.
I WILL UNDERSTAND RESIGN.
NO WAY.
>> Laura: HE SAID RESIGNING
WOULD BE TURNING HIS BACK ON THE
TROOPS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> MY THOUGHTS ARE, OUR SON SAID
TO HIM IF YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS
A BAD IDEA, ARE YOU WILLING TO
SAY I WON'T PUT OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN PERIL?
HE SAID HAVE DROPPED THE REIN
AND RESIGNED AND SAID I WILL NOT
DO THIS IT TO OUR
MEMBERS.
HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
LET ME EXPLAIN WHY THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS SO IMPORTANT.
DURING THE WAR IN LAST 20 YEARS
WE LOST AROUND 7,000 TROOPS.
WE HAVE LOST IN THE LAST 20
YEARS BETWEEN 30 UP TO 100,000
TROOPS FROM SUICIDE.
THEY NEED THAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY DID
MATTERED.
SO MANY LIVES TO BE SAVED ON THE
BACK SIDE BY BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I SAY TAKE THAT REIN AND PUT IT
DOWN AND STAND UP FOR YOUR OTHER
SERVICE MEMBER AND FOR MY SON
AND FOR AMERICA.
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
>> BASICALLY, THEY LET HUNDREDS
OF AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE LEAVING OUR SON TONIGHT
IN IT PRISON.
THAT'S NOT OKAY WITH US.
I CHALLENGE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE:
IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
IS IT OKAY WITH YOU THAT
A 17-YEAR INFANTRY OFFICER THAT
PUT HIS LIFE ON THE LINE TO
PROTECT YOU AND PROTECT YOUR
CHILDREN, IS IT OKAY WITH YOU
THAT HE IS PUT IN JAIL AND IS
FACING A COURT MARTIAL.
HE DIDN'T MURDER ANYONE OR
SEXUALLY OFFEND ANYONE OR DO
DRUGS.
HE ASKED FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY COULD NOT HANDLE IT.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
IT'S SHAMEFUL.
IF IT'S NOT OKAY FOR YOU,
AMERICANS, WE ARE ASKING YOU TO
STAND UP, WRITE YOUR
CONGRESSMAN, DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT'S NOT JUST ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE BOTCHED AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL OR PEOPLE LEFT
BEHIND.
THE ONLY ONE BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS BOTCHED
SITUATION IS MY SON BY THE
GENERALS.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY THIS.
YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY
MOUTH.
SENATOR COTTON ASKED DEFENSE
SECRETARY AUSTIN ABOUT YOUR
SON'S CONFINEMENT.
>> THERE WAS A CRITICAL VIDEO ON
SOCIAL MEDIA LAST MONTH AND HE
WAS RELIEVED OF HIS COMMAND.
HE IS BEING HELD IN PRE-TRIAL
CONFINEMENT.
WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFICS OF
WHAT CAUSED HIM TO BE HELD IN
PRE-TRIAL CONFINEMENT.
I WOULD CERTAINLY ASK THE
MARINES TO PROVIDE THAT INSIGHT.
>> Laura: CATHY, HE IS THE
PENTAGON CHIEF!
THIS YOUNG MAN IS IN MILITARY
JAIL.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT AUSTIN
HAS NO IDEA WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I COULD NOT BELIEVE THOSE
WORDS CAME OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
IF HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON, SHAME ON HIM IF HE IS
TOTALLY UNAWARE.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE ARE AWARE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THEM
TAKE THEIR DIRTY LITTLE SECRET
AND HIDE IT AWAY AND PUT OUR SON
SO HE CAN'T SPEAK AND TAKE HIM
AWAY FROM FREEDOM OF SPEECH SO
THEY CAN HIDE THEIR LITTLE
SECRET.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: JOE BIDEN COMPAINED AS
A PRESIDENT THAT WOULD BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESTORING
DIGNITY -- THAT WAS A BIG PART
OF HIS CAMPAIGN AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO WIN THIS
ELECTION.
HE IS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF NOW.
YOUR SON VIOLATED ORDERS FROM
YOUR COMMANDERS ACCORDING TO THE
LAW?
>> I GET THAT LT. COL. CAUSED
PROBLEMS FOR THE MARINE CORPS
AND THE MILITARY BY BREAKING THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND.
HE KNOWS IT.
AND IT WILL BE TALKED ABOUT FOR
DECADES IN THE FUTURE OF WHAT
STEWART HAS DONE WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA AND IT'S A PROBLEM FOR THE
MARINE CORPS.
WHILE STEWART BROKE THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND, GENERAL McKENZIE AND
GENERAL MILLEY AND SECRETARY
AUSTIN BROKE THE CHAIN OF TRUST
AND CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
FOR THAT, THEY SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED.
>> THEY IT SHOULD THEIR RANK AND
RESIGN FOR THAT.
>> TODAY'S HEARING SHOWED THEY
WON'T ACCEPT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE MISTAKES THEY MADE.
THEY WANTED TO BLAME EVERYBODY
ELSE -- THE AFGHAN MILITARY AND
THE WEATHER.
I AM TELLING YOU, THEY SHOULD
RESIGN.
>> Laura: SHOULDN'T THEY ARE
FIRED?
>> YOU AND I BOTH KNOW JOE BIDEN
IS NOT GOING TO FIRE THEM.
>> FOR MY SON WE HAVE TO GET
WORD OUT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON.
HE NEEDS OUR HELP.
WE ARE ASKING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO WRITE THEIR
CONGRESSMAN TO SAY IT'S NOT ALL
RIGHT WITH THEM.
WE WANT THEM TO RESIGN AND WE
WANT STUART RELEASED.
WE WOULD LIKE HIM TO HAVE HIS
PENSION REINSTATED AND HIS
MILITARY BENEFITS THAT HE WILL
NEED.
IF THEY WON'T DO THAT AT LEAST
RELEASE HIM AND LET HIM OUT OF
THE MARINES.
HE ASKED FOR THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR.
WE ARE ASKING FOR PEOPLE TO
SUPPORT HIS FAMILY BY GOING TO
PIPEFITTER
PIPEFIT
PIPEFITTERSFOUNDATION.ORG.
HIS FAMILY NEEDS FUNDING TO
LIVE.
>> Laura: THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
THE LEGAL FEES.
WE WILL WORK ON THAT.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS!
THIS IS A TRAVESTY WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOUR SON.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUING
WILL BE OVER IN DAYS OR WEEKS,
BUT WE OUR EXPECTATION VISIT
BEEN LEVELED BY STUART'S LEGAL
TEAM THAT THE MARINES COULD DRAG
THIS OUT FOR YEARS.
THEIR OBJECTIVE -- AND BY THE
WAY, PRE-TRIAL CONFINEMENT IS
A NICE COMFORTABLE WORD.
>> Laura: IS YOUR SON A FLIGHT
RISK?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> NO.
HE LOVES THIS COUNTRY.
HE LOVES AMERICA.
>> Laura: SO THEY DON'T WANT HIM
TO TALK?
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHAT ELSE
HE MIGHT SAY?
>> THEY DON'T WANT HIM TO TALK.
THEY HAVE NOT EVEN BROUGHT
CHARGES ON HIM AND THEY ARE
HOLDING HIM IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
>> IF THAT'S NOT OKAY --
>> Laura: THEY SEEM TO LIKE
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT LATELY.
ALL OF THE CIVILIAN RIGHTS FOLKS
SAID IT WAS CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT BUT LOOSE IT AGAINST
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
-- USE IT.
YOUR SON'S STATE OF MIND?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I CAN'T TALK TO HIM.
HE IS NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE PHONE
CALLS.
>> WE TALKED TO HIM FOR 2
MINUTES ON MONDAY MORNING.
>> Laura: THIS CAN'T BE OUR
COUNTRY.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE THE MARINE
CORPS IS CALLING US TO LET US
KNOW.
>> Laura: WOULD HAVE THIS
HAPPENED UNDER TRUMP?
>> NO, WE WOULD NOT HAVE HAD THE
BOTCHED EXIT UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IN MY OPINION.
I DON'T THINK STU WOULD HAVE
DONE WHAT HE DID AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP WOULD HAVE STEPPED IN.
>> Laura: THIS STORY IS NOT
GOING AWAY.
I BET THE COUNTRY IS WITH YOU.
WE WILL KEEP IN IT TOUCH WITH
YOU AND GET T